cherry lagarde il aura notamment qui
nous a rejoint cette année
et regardez il s'est mis dans la peau
d'un chauffeur über il va rendre fou les
gens c'est grey guillotin c'est parti
bon c'est bonjour bonjour bonjour
bienvenue dans mon véhicule
bonjour messieurs dames c'est bon ça va
aller trouver des doux j'aime bien les
schémas mois donc fait bien rire les
chinois j'adore 1
on a envie de faire des bisous vous
savez pourquoi
le football c'est drôle parce que
thierry henry
je vais proposer un pack d'eau et vous
savez que jackie chan sort son nouveau
film we
ça doit être une star pour vous oui
enfin j'imagine c'est la star de tous
les chinois
qu'est ce qui vous a mené ce métier le
dialogue avec les clients leur faire
plaisir
les rendre heureux joyeux vous rentrez
dans mon véhicule et ces choses vous
prenez du bonheur en plein visage
c'est comme une éjaculation de bonheur
en fait savoir sa part d'un coup ou pas
vous le recevez en pleine faciale c'est
du vrai bonheur à l'état pur pourtant
jacky savaient pas très chinois quand on
y réfléchit
ça fait plus penser à jacky le club
dorothée ariane le club dorothée elle
habite à de rudes et si je vous ai amené
si vous voulez vous êtes ensemble depuis
longtemps
waouh c'est beau j'ai une copine depuis
deux semaines mais à chaque fois que je
mets la capote
ça veut pas passer je sais pas s'il va
pas me laisser tomber parce que elle
commence à trop s'impatienter quoi tous
ces mêmes pages à un gros zizis parce
que j'ai même un tout petit zizi pour
vous dire et j'ai pas c'est même pas la
taille du sexe qui bloquent un est une
start-up que vous connaissez qui
asiatiques aussi c'est brandon de l'île
de la tentation qui était marié à maria
diana brandon et diana ça vous dit rien
ils ont monté un restaurant
je vais vous montrer ensuite oui je suis
un peu pressé d'accord vous n'avez pas
trop l'île de la tentation vous c'est
vous monsieur vous avez un gros un petit
zizi à peu près 1 jusqu'à la taille avec
les mains nous regarder cette faillite à
vous pensez que ça va être la taille du
monsieur saïd emin sacré bon bout eh oui
ça vous permet de tenir l'équilibré
voyez cette rue oui la perpendiculaire
après vous prenez la perpendiculaire et
ensuite la prochaine à gauche et le
restaurant de brandon et diana l'île de
la tentation
ok ok merci oui j'essaie de parler trop
vite pour pas vous faire de secours et
lippi et à charly nestor qui est voisin
du restaurant c'est charly nestor de
charly et lulu le gros des missions qui
étaient huit machines ça passait dans
les années 90 peut-être que vous avez vu
quand billy crawford est passé à un fil
et pin up crois que mes bébés ce texte
est nommé aussi c'est bien sûr parce que
je vous aime bien en vrai c'est je
voudrais pas vous laisser descendre trop
vite vous êtes frères et soeurs vous
êtes en couple la famille oui d'accord
et vous faites jamais l'amour tous les
trois essais c'est des choses qui
arrivent et ça ça veut dire à mon avis
est que vous avez déjà touché les idées
aussi c'est mon envie c'est que vous
avez vous demandé d'accord excusez moi
pour mon impolitesse voulez du cac
je fais une petite pause on se prend un
petit café ce que vous saviez qu'on
consacre des pur sang de notre vie sur
le téléphone
s'il vous plaît vous nous direz un le
scaf s'il vous plaît
pourquoi monsieur ben ça nous dérange
déjà on va s'arrêter prendre un café
tous les quatre non non non on me dit
qu'on a besoin de travailler oui je sais
alors écoutez je vais attendre en bas de
chez vous vous envoyez votre mail je
suis là voilà les choses se terminent
toujours bien vous voyez en dix minutes
on sera passé par des hauts et des bas
ces quatre dans toutes les aventures
dans toutes les amitiés c'est comme une
relation avec ma femme
des fois on sur les assiettes dans la
figure et après on fait l'amour comme
des singes
attendez ne descendez pas c'est moi qui
vais me descend de vous offrir le
plaisir est pour moi merci hein pas gros
chacun à ceyrat cadeau un cadeau
d'autant que vous mettez 5 étoiles
m'apprenez les packs d'eau